[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano en france24
bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días comenzamos
con los titulares en argel el primer
ministro italiano mario draghi fue
recibido por el presidente abdel majid
debut italia busca romper su dependencia
del gas ruso recurriendo a países
africanos
precisamente argelia se está
convirtiendo en un país clave en el
contexto de la crisis energética
vamos a mali la junta gubernamental
suspendió la emisión militar de naciones
de naciones unidas en el país una
decisión que llega después de la
detención en bamako de 49 soldados
marfileños las autoridades malienses los
consideran mercenarios y estaremos en
casa de la alemania donde se dieron cita
a algunos de los colectivos artísticos
más reconocidos de áfrica en la
exposición documenta uno de los eventos
de arte contemporáneo más importantes
del mundo
en el marco de la cuarta cumbre argelino
italiana argelia firmó una serie de
acuerdos para aumentar sus exportaciones
de gas a italia convirtiéndose así en su
mayor proveedor los países de la unión
europea intentan sustituir el gasto ruso
para presionar a moscú que continúa en
guerra contra ucrania los varios países
europeos han firmado acuerdos
comerciales y energéticos con argel un
país clave para paliar la crisis
energética
con su segunda visita en tres meses
mario draghi es casi un habitual del
palacio presidencial argelino
esta vez el jefe de gobierno italiano
que preside la cuarta cumbre argelina
italiana con el presidente abdel majid
debut pero sobre todo firma acuerdos
comerciales su gran prioridad es
sustituir el gas ruso del que italia
depende en un 45% argelia se comprometió
a aumentar sus exportaciones
argelia se ha convertido en el principal
exportador de gas a italia
la unión europea decidió reducir su
consumo de gas ruso para protestar
contra la invasión de ucrania y
presionar a vladimir putin para los
países del bloque especialmente los que
dependen en gran medida de moscú es una
carrera contrarreloj para encontrar
alternativas mario draghi y sus
ministros estuvieron visitando congo
brazzaville y angola libia y los
emiratos árabes unidos- un buen punto
para italia hay gasoductos que le unen a
argelia y libia y el gigante energético
italiano eni es el mayor productor de
gas en áfrica desde principios de año
argelia ya ha aumentado los volúmenes
suministrados italia en un 113% el
objetivo es evitar el desabastecimiento
el bloqueo de las industrias italianas y
para frenar la subida de los precios
en mali la junta militar suspendió las
operaciones de los contingentes
militares y policiales de la misión de
la onu en el país la misma las
autoridades malienses justificaron su
decisión por el contexto de una supuesta
amenaza a la seguridad nacional y es que
la medida llega cuatro días después de
la detención de 49 soldados marfileños
que bamako consideran mercenarios y que
acusa de intentar romper la dinámica de
reconstrucción del estado maliense sin
embargo costa de márfil niega esta
versión y asegura que los soldados
fueron desplegados en mali como parte de
una misión de apoyo a los contingentes
de naciones unidas
busutil se dio un tiro y sutura para
apoyar a sus dos contingentes en la
misma la compañía que se encuentra en la
ciudad de monte y el batallón en la
ciudad de tombuctú necesito otras
autorización de la onu y después de un
memorando de entendimiento con empresas
a helen aviation services establecer
elementos de apoyo nacionales capital
bamako como base logística avanzada
con esta base compartida con otros
países como alemania etcétera transitan
nuestros materiales nuestros equipos y
nuestros numerosos militares que tenemos
allí en contingentes así como nuestros
expertos con los que trabajamos en
nombre de la misma así que no hay nada
que no esté claro
veamos en detalle de qué trata la misión
de naciones unidas en mal en la misma es
una operación de la onu para el
mantenimiento de la paz que fue
establecida en el marco de la guerra
civil maliense fue creada el 25 de abril
de 2013 su mandato consta de varios
puntos entre ellos
estabilizar la situación en las zonas
más pobladas
contribuye al restablecimiento de la
autoridad del estado en todo el
territorio maliense y proteger a los
civiles y al personal de la onu en este
país
la minustah está formada por unos 12.600
efectivos procedentes principalmente de
los ejércitos de chad nigeria benin
burkina faso togo y senegal sin embargo
progresivamente las autoridades y parte
de la población civil han perdido la
confianza en la misión dado que no
impidió el golpe militar de 2020 ni el
deterioro de la seguridad en el país por
los ataques de grupos extremistas
nos quedamos en el sahel pero cambiamos
de país
reforzar la operación marcan en níger
esta es la decisión tomada por los
ministros franceses y nigerianos el
objetivo es redefinir la asociación
militar entre ambos países para hacer
frente a los grupos armados que asolan
esta región del continente
una reunión entre las delegaciones de
francia y de níger en un momento en el
que paris busca profundizar su
asociación con níger en la lucha contra
el terrorismo entre otros objetivos
observa por más que lograr estamos aquí
para demostrar el compromiso de francia
junto a las autoridades nigerianas y
para responder lo mejor posible a las
necesidades que nos han expresado ya sea
en materia de ayuda al desarrollo de
seguridad o de lucha contra el
terrorismo egoísmos francia que ha
desplegado miles de tropas en mali
durante varios años ha sido expulsada de
este país por la junta militar que
asumió el mando en agosto de 2020 pero
el ejército del país galo continuará su
cooperación con níger donde mantendrá
más de 1000 hombres tres aviones de
combate seis drones armados y entre
cuatro y seis helicópteros cuando llegue
el momento se tratará de hacer
propuestas a los jefes de estado francés
y nigeriano para ver qué forma qué
geografía qué planificación qué doctrina
deben tener nuestras fuerzas armadas
precisamente para luchar contra el
terrorismo en la zona este es el mandato
que se ha dado a nuestros dos jefes de
estado mayor hacer propuestas a la
autoridad política
el sahel la metodología de las
intervenciones militares francesas ha
cambiado en los últimos años ya no se
trata de que los soldados actúen solos
sino de que apoyen a las fuerzas locales
de acuerdo a sus peticiones la visita de
los dos ministros a níger se produce
también en un momento en el que el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón busca
redefinir su oferta militar y
diplomática en el sahel así como en el
continente europeo en donde el pedido al
ministro al jefe del estado mayor de las
fuerzas armadas que pueda realizar en
las próximas semanas una reevaluación a
la luz del nuevo contexto geopolítico un
nuevo contexto político
este trabajo dará lugar a una nueva
significación para poder posicionarnos
con más fuerza en la evaluación tanto de
la amenaza como de las realidades que
estamos viviendo en el teatro de
operaciones del sahel en esta guerra de
alta intensidad que ha vuelto a suelo
europeo
los ejércitos franceses también están
presentes en senegal gabón costa de
márfil inútil además de la cooperación
militar
parís y niamey firmaran un préstamo de
50 millones de euros y una donación de
20 millones de euros para níger
cambiamos de tema y de continente en
kassel a alemania a estos días se dan
cita a algunos de los colectivos
artísticos más reconocidos de áfrica en
la exposición documenta uno de los
eventos de arte contemporáneo más
reconocidos del mundo la primera edición
tuvo lugar poco después de la segunda
guerra mundial y desde entonces se
celebra cada cinco años la dirección
artística de esta edición número 15 de
documenta está a cargo de air one group
a un colectivo de indonesia con larga
trayectoria que ha elegido a artistas de
áfrica américa latina y asia para que
ocupen el escenario central de la
muestra nuestro corresponsal salem fayad
se unió con un artista ghanés
el arte contemporáneo los artistas
africanos piensan muy fuerte aquí en
casa en la edición número 15 documenta
una exposiciones de arte contemporáneo
más prestigiosas del mundo y que se
celebra entre junio y septiembre de este
año
antiguas fábricas abandonadas piscinas
vacías iglesias parques galerías y por
supuesto museos son el escenario de la
documenta de este año y aparte el
extenso programa de exposiciones hay
también una ambiciosa agenda de talleres
y seminarios y de residencias artísticas
en los que han sido invitados artistas
de diferentes partes del mundo entre
ellos está el artista de ghana 4 gene
quien comentó sobre el enfoque la
exposición de este año así como la
importancia que tiene partidistas
africanos a ser parte de esta plataforma
sobre un local de media
entrada sabaté si nos fijamos en las
principales exposiciones de arte del
mundo vemos que la participación de
culturas africanas y de otras culturas
no europeas se está volviendo mucho más
evidente mucho más masivo
y el enfoque que tiene esta decisión de
documenta es bastante radical es un
importante paso simbólico hacia la
descolonización externa
en
acción y columna de 6 jones más que en
artistas individuales documental número
15 está haciendo un énfasis en
colectivos de artistas y sobre todo del
sur global por lo tanto la
representación de artistas africanos
tiene una presencia bastante importante
está representado por artistas por
ejemplo de gran relevancia del
continente como dennis collective de
kenia la que le queda library de
sudáfrica el colectivo de cineastas
huacal y bud de uganda así como el
festival por el río níger de mali eso
son fotos que también es importante
crear espacios para nosotros mismos no
sólo se trata de que nos reciban aquí
hostería world arts sino que buscamos
revertir la dinámica poder volver a casa
y aún tener visibilidad y aragón a esto
miles cada colectivo tiene un espacio en
el que montan instalaciones multimedia
en los que las narrativas de coloniales
son un común denominador pero también
temas como la migración los derechos
lgtb y la represión política el cambio
climático son parte de la agenda y es
claro que en la curaduría de documenta
de este año el arte es un vehículo para
reflexionar sobre las situaciones
políticas y sociales que afectan a los
países del sur global
desmitificar el arte es algo vital
nosotros hemos heredado nociones del
gobierno colonial británico lo cual ha
confinado lo que podría ser nuestra
concepción sobre el arte wotawa
concepción así que para nosotros la idea
es liberarnos de esto para que nuevas
prácticas puedan parecer new para que
sus usuarios
así despedimos la edición de esta semana
gracias por acompañarnos la información
continúa en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]